voilà pourtant il existe un abruti jour
messieurs dames
qu'est ce que c'est que ce encore je
vois mon papa même si dans sa lettre mon
père reconnaît explicitement l'exigence
de l'enfant parce qu'il le dit bien
comment va la petite ya des dettes va
depuis ta pour une recherche en
paternité largement dépassé touristes à
8 ou remises à savoir si elle est où
maintenant ta maman existait à l'époque
le préservatif ferme les kwassa des
sucrettes gamme moussa cinq minutes on
voit remettre votre sort non mais cette
dame n'est pas ma soeur et son joli les
sucrettes à tout much mais sait pas
pourquoi il est beau au café ans une
affection
mais quand tu as une seule depuis hier
bien faire un bisou à mon fils aime et
vous a proposé de 8 et a vécu
oui ça lui ressemble pas parce que j'ai
changé je fais tu là vous y arrêter un
type bien mais c'était pas de ta faute
tu était défoncée qu'est ce que j'ai
fait bon vous prenez vos affaires vous
partez
tadic on se quittait plus jamais
oh
qu'est ce que vous comptez faire avec
lesquels soeur qu'elle sort
j'ai le theme from hell cauchemar